Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Wow. This is a historic moment today. Let
me tell you why. DeepMind just introduced
their new system called AlphaDev and it
is based on something they call AlphaZero.
AlphaZero was an AI system that
could learn to play Chess, Go,
and Shogi by playing against itself. So
how good is it? Well, it is incredible.
And I really mean that, this is an AI that
can beat world champions in these games.
Now I hope you allow me to quote
myself from about 400 videos ago:
“The point of AlphaZero is not to solve Chess,
or any of these games. Its main point is to
show that a general AI can be created that
can perform on a superhuman level on not one,
but several different tasks at the same time.“
It can learn as long as we formulate the problem
as a video game. For instance, it is easy to
think about Chess like we think about a game,
because that’s exactly what it is. If you win,
you get some points, if you lose, you lose some
points. Simple. However, what their new AI,
AlphaDev does is computer coding. Excuse
me, what? How is coding a video game?
Yes, it really imagines computer coding as a video
game. You see, in the case of sorting numbers,
the computer game level will be a series of
numbers, and the actions that we perform with
a controller in a game will be writing code. If
this code is written well, it will sort these
numbers correctly, in which case, oh yes, that’s
right, we get a nice score. But let’s add a twist
to the game: latency. Correctness is necessary,
but the faster the code, the higher the score.
I love it. Coding as a video game. That
sounds nice. However, I doubt it will be
able to say anything new as sorting is a very
well studied area in computer science. This is
one of the first things every computer scientist
starts learning about and there are hundreds and
hundreds of algorithms published in this area.
I don’t expect that this will be able to say
anything truly new here, but if it can at least
match what humans can do, that would be nice.
And…what? Look at that! Am I dreaming
or is this real? On shorter sequences,
it is up to 70% faster, and even on big workloads,
it is about 1.7% faster than the currently used
techniques. My goodness! And if that is at
all possible, it gets even better. Get this,
they have deployed it into the LLVM libc++
sorting library. What does that mean? Well,
hold on to your papers Fellow Scholars, because
it likely means that that it is now being used
more than a trillions times a day. Wow. If
someone finds out something new and useful
in the area of physical manufacturing, it might
very well take decades for a paper to see any
use in the real world. However, here, we are
going from paper to product not in decades,
and not even in years. This is
tech transfer in a matter of days.
And this is an AI that can say, I got
this, don’t worry about it. Just tell
me what you wish to see, and I’ll write
this software on my own. And don’t forget,
this is a difficult game. It is like constructing
a skyscraper…from scratch! One wrong move,
and you are done. And it is not just
as good as the collective intelligence
of humanity, but it even exceeds it.
My goodness. What a time to be alive!
And interestingly, it also doesn’t write
C++, but it writes Assembly code directly,
this roughly means that it is really low to
the ground. This is a bit closer to the metal,
the hardware itself. Proper coding skills
from an AI that even rivals humans.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!